the Joe Rogan experience I think it's
important to have fairness in this this
is why I'm so pro you sada I love what
they're doing I love the fact that
they're testing the [ __ ] out of people
they're just showing up in people's
houses 6 o'clock the morning hey wake up
time for a test and but is it the same
in in every country that's good question
it's a very good question Brian if
someone's training in Russia or Germany
or wherever yeah that's a very good
question I do not know the answer to
that because I know that's kind of one
of the concerns or something oddly it's
that yeah I might be really strict here
mm-hmm in the States but in other states
as strict right because it is US
anti-doping agency that's you sada yeah
that's a good question yeah so what do
you think you don't think it is I don't
know I'll talk for you if there's
something [ __ ] up you need to say just
go like this okay I don't know um I
guess I just I I can only be concerned
with what's under my control
right so then I'm just gonna train and
I'm gonna get as good as I can get and
hopefully you know you sada can can take
care of the rest but for me to stress
about it is it's just time wasted I
think for myself well I do know of a
case where there was a fighter who told
me that there was a guy who was openly
dirty as far as what everybody knew and
he knew that he was gonna piss hot so he
went and did some seminars in another
country he just stayed over in another
country for it just moved around it's
like so you see this world-class fighter
in these weird little gyms it was like
what is going on over there and the
gentleman who told me said listen man
he's docking drug tests that's what he's
doing over there that's crazy
yeah for sure like when you when the
kind of TJ Dillashaw gets popped and you
like wow
TJ for a world title he's getting popped
like how many people are getting away
with this how many people got away with
this it's just not worth it
he lost a lot doing that what he oh yeah
you know it's not worth it it's not
worth it
ultimately it's definitely not worth it
because his legacies tainted but if he
got away with it is it worth it I mean
how many people got away with it here's
the question how many people retired
and we never got to see their drug test
from 2006-2008 like what were you taking
Louie on like back when they used to
have those silly wait drug tests or
their chests you at the weigh ins which
is basically a intelligence test like
yeah you still taking steroids or did
you stop a couple of weeks ago and the
testing today is so much more
sophisticated that's why people getting
popped for EPO and a bunch of things
that were hard too hard to find yeah
they're the thresholds like this is the
john jones thing with the pika grams
what the the insignificant amount in
terms of like the performance-enhancing
aspect of it that is in his system like
how can they detect that well they can
detect that because the machines are way
more sophisticated the drug testings way
like he if he had tested if John Jones
had tested two years ago he would have
tested clean yeah but now it's just
they're just way better to tell even
something less even if you're taking
creatine and that creatine is tainted
yeah which is a lot of it what these
guys Tim means that was his deal he was
taking a supplement it was tainted quite
a few guys yeah have legitimately just
taken over-the-counter supplements that
they thought were clean and they got
something anything just some tiny fret
that doesn't have any effect on their
performance but it shows up and he'll
show up for months and weeks and John's
case like years he's been showing up for
like a year and a half comes on and off
and when you're cutting weight that's
when it seems to come back that's what
it seems to show because your body's
gone mm-hmm you're losing fat you're
losing you're losing body weight some of
that's stored in fat they think it's
very confusing for them they're trying
to figure it all out and then any all
these [ __ ] people online or ranting
and raving about pika grams and this
like the science experts and they think
it's I think it's all [ __ ] that
John's allowed to fight you should be
banned for life and like okay you know
you're not listening like he tested
negative and then he tested positive a
week later and then he tested negative a
week after that like what's happening
here something weirds happening there so
figuring out for themselves exactly yeah
but I'm glad they're figuring it out
[Applause]